foreign
[Music]
good afternoon good evening everybody
thank you for attending here and
attending online uh what may be our last
event of the Year there might be another
one that would just take advantage of an
opportunity in a couple of weeks my name
is anatadamati and I'm a finance
Professor here at Stanford Business
School and founder and faculty director
of the cooperation Society initiative
Cassie that's sponsoring this event in
addition to myself and my fellow
co-faculty director Paul floyder Cassidy
by staff director Lisa Simpson or she
over there and uh by a wonderful group
of student leaders one of whom some new
come here is
taking the questions from the zoom
audience
Cassie focuses on the challenge of
ensuring that corporations best serve
society and what we recognize is that
what's critical to this
Pursuit is to get the governance right
in all institutions in the private
sector and in government effective
governance is the opposite of corruption
which is defined as the abuse of
entrusted power for private gains that
means that people with power are
accountable when their decisions impact
others
Sunshine is the best disinfectant goes
to saying and so secrecy is the enemy of
effective governance
and it's a great friend and enabler of
corruption
we live in a global world and in this
world secrecy and dirty money flows is
an opaque subject that many prefer not
to discuss
we're a very special guest this evening
to actually discuss it so it works we're
so excited to host him I met Raymond
Baker in December 2022 in an
International anti-corruption Conference
in Washington D.C
I got interested in intercorruption
efforts and I assigned myself to the
newsletter of Transparency International
and anti-corruption cooperation where
you would get these kinds of email like
this week in corruption and
um one they were asking people to
propose panels for this anti-crustion
conferences for the first time was held
in DC Washington DC in the USA
and so I decided over the summer to come
up with a panel proposal for them and it
was very related to the previous speaker
that we had here in Gnomeo reska who
spoke about uh the big myth and she's
the author of merchants of Doubt which
is about climate denialism and uh my
panel was entitled on the corruption of
knowledge and what academics can do and
it meant to explore the way in which
people confuse other people or confuse
the the policy or hide certain things or
just have tell certain narratives
something that I encountered myself in
in my engagement with policy and that no
more rescue encountered the same and I
asked so our panel was not accepted to
this conference it was in that context
that contacted nomaresca and found out
that she had that book forth coming and
when I went to the conference and asked
for I went to a couple of days to just
see that crowd in that area they didn't
take my panel but I wanted to see what
this is all about and why they may have
not been ready for my panel or whatever
and I asked to meet people who were in
interested in corruption including uh
very subtle forms of corruption that or
are they enabling of corruption that
comes from developed countries so they
encounter with sort of capitalism if you
wish the kind of stuff we teach here at
the business school and so among the
introductions that people who were
helping me meet the right crowd over
there I was introduced to Raymond and
Raymond gave me an advanced copy of the
book that we have right there invisible
trillions which I read this was in
December just a few months ago and I
think Raymond said to me that uh he is
probably the only MBA in this conference
which had thousands of people and I
could assure him that I was the only
business school professor in the entire
place so we were both unique in being
there at all coming from this world of
Business Schools business education and
uh in our conversation uh after giving
me the book he said do you think
Business Schools are ready to engage in
this topic
said well Cassie is
so here we are with this event I also
was very happy to discover that Larry
Diamond who's this friend of Cassie and
an Affiliated faculty and I helped us
organize a conference on corporations
and democracy that we had virtually in
December 2020 all available on our
website uh wrote the preface of this
book
and we were fortunate to be able to get
Larry to converse with uh Raymond Baker
on this book and on the issues so uh
I'll give a very brief introduction I
mean Raymond's uh bio is like it would
take hours so I will just give you
simple highlights he graduated from that
other business school that also Lisa
graduated from and the East Coast
Harvard in with an MBA
in 1960 or many in the room were barely
were not born or were small children
and he started his career in Africa so
the question is how did he get to talk
about dirty money and all of that well
obviously there was you know more than
60 years ago so there's many years in
between and uh in those years he worked
in Africa and Nigeria for 15 years and
this was the start of a lot of global
flows and he started noticing things and
then he started looking into things in
the 90s and um wrote a paper entitled
the biggest loophole in free market
system in 1999 a paper and later in 2005
a book called
um and the other things about Dirty
Money the book entitled capitalism's
Achilles heel dirty money and how to
renew free market system so we talked
last time about the big myth of free
markets and he is now talking about it
here so he found it also right after the
Global Financial integrity and nonprofit
in DC
and on the board of Transparency
International Etc so this book appeared
just a few months ago uh like in January
February of 2023 and
um
anyway I'm gonna stop here he got a
MacArthur Foundation Grant he traveled
lots of countries I can't possibly go
through all of this
Larry diamond is has very fancy titles
I'll keep that one short too because
that one's also very long uh William
Clayton senior fellow at Hoover
institution must backer I don't know how
to pronounce it senior fellow at Global
democracy at the Freeman sparkling
Institute where he has multiple programs
that he's directing he's all over the
place writing books and editing books
about democracy uh Journal of democracy
founder etc etc I wrote a book called
ill wins saving democracy from Russian
rage Chinese ambition in American
complacency
so I am going to let the two of them
take it from here Larry will converse
with him and then we'll turn to audience
questions thank you
[Applause]
I I could have and I probably should
have extended uh the subtitle to include
complacency about uh the system of
financial secrecy and what it's doing to
undermine both capitalism and democracy
though as Raymond knows I I do have a
chapter uh in my book about kleptocracy
but I just want to say this is the book
uh on the subject and
um it is both uh elusive an extremely
readable in fact I would say at times
gripping uh analysis of the problem
highly accessible and very constructive
it's got a lot of in addition to uh an
orienting posture as you'll hear it's
got a lot of very specific ideas on on
what we need to do and I think to
understand the problem you need to
understand it at thirty thousand feet
which is hopefully the opening of what
we're going to talk about and then you
need to understand that a lot of the
devil is in the details so Raymond uh
thank you so much for writing this book
and thank you so much for coming here
you want to begin by just uh you know
making a few opening remarks including
telling us how you got into this
experience and how this book evolved
from your last book in 2005. all right
thank you Larry the first thing I want
to do is to thank you for writing the uh
forward of my book I don't know how many
of you know this gentleman's nickname it
is Mr democracy he was recognized by the
National Endowment of democracy last
year for His stunning contributions to
uh
to this so I'm extremely pleased Larry
to share this with you again
how did I get into all of this
um yes I graduated from Harvard Business
School in 1960 I didn't really know what
I wanted to do I did a couple of things
and then I decided I wanted to get a
taste of international business without
making any long-range commitment to it
just get it safe so I sent my resume out
to a bunch of Corporations ended up
getting three offers one to go to Iran
one to go to Nigeria and one to go to
Brazil I chose Nigeria because the newly
independent country it was English
speaking and I could walk off the plane
and manage the entity that I was hired
to manage so I went to Nigeria and um
you know without any idea of of
what I was going to be what I was
getting into
but I
encountered an old coaster a British
gentleman who had been in West Africa
for decades
and he was managing director of a
Trading Company in Nigeria and I asked
him how do you do business in Africa and
this guy looked me up one side and down
the other he wasn't the least bit
forthcoming I I got the impression that
he didn't like Americans showing up in
his ex-british Colony just one year
after Independence
um but I I pressed on with this guy and
I said I said to him okay well tell me
how do you price your imported cars and
building materials and textiles to sell
in the Nigerian market and the guy looks
at me with complete disdain and he says
price
price is not a problem I'm not trying to
make a profit
I had just finished Harvard Business
School
instead of all about how to make a
profit if this guy says I'm not trying
to make it I had no idea what he was
talking about what he was talking about
as I learned later was transfer pricing
everything that he imported from the
parent company in the UK was overpriced
so that when he sold it in Nigeria all
he had to do was to pay the invoices on
what was imported and the profits were
shifted back out of the country that was
the first time I had any concept of this
um after
um
settling this into my thinking I
eventually realized that virtually every
foreign company operating in Nigeria was
doing the same thing and then I realized
that a lot of Nigerians were doing the
same thing using trade for the purpose
of Shifting money abroad
move forward now for a little bit after
I spent two years running that company I
um I set up on my own and
I got married to Pauline as you know
um
yes and
proceeded to starve the death for the
first year until I got some Consulting
contracts and got my feet on the ground
a little bit and then I was hit with the
Nigerian civil war
the biafran conflict and I thought to
myself you know I'm playing a zero-sum
game here I'm either going to figure out
how to make it or I'm going to lose my
shirt and go back and never admit it
anyway so I I started buying small and
medium-sized companies that I could
afford to buy
that other people who were obviously
smarter than me were selling out I
bought their companies made my biggest
Acquisitions
in the Civil War and right as the war
was ending which leads me to another
story that I want to tell
the war ended in 1970
um
I had my eye on a particular
manufacturing company that I wanted to
buy
and had been following this company for
three years and and and was just
determined I was going to get my hands
on it
um I this company
had lost money every year for five years
that it had been in business I offered
10 times Book value
to buy the company two years later
Harvard Business School wrote a case
study on this acquisition and this and
the case study included the balance
sheets and the income statements and the
fact that it was nearly bankrupt having
lost money every year that had been
created
um and and the materials talked about
the economy of Nigeria they just come
out of the Civil War and so forth
and the students were asked should
should this individual buy this company
I'm sitting in the back of the room they
don't know that it's me sitting back
there in that corner and so the students
discussed discussed this case and then
the professor took a vote how many of
you think that this you know this is a
this guy should buy this company one
hundred percent of the students said
this is a dog this is a turkey don't buy
this company don't even think about
buying it anybody that would give this
any consideration must have been out in
the tropical sun too long so I you know
I was then invited to come down front or
just there and I told the students not
only did we buy it but we paid off all
of its debts in the first year and
generous dividends to myself and
minority shareholders for years
thereafter
how did we do it where we managed with
Geniuses no all we did was buy imported
raw materials at World Market prices the
other family had been overpricing the
import of raw materials for the specific
purpose of Shifting money out of the
country we didn't do that we operated it
properly we it turned out to be the most
profitable company uh
that I've ever owned but those two
experiences within the first decade of
my uh business career have shaped
um
my approach to this I have been
fascinated for years with the way in
which
the capitalist system is operating in
the shadows out of sight in ways that
make money for some people and lose
money for other people
I want to get into uh that phenomenon in
some detail before I do I just have to
say uh you know uh by way of of noting
the interesting parallel that the way I
got into this issue was also as you know
my engaging Nigeria and by living there
for a year in 1982-83 and watching the
politicians of the second Republic
absolutely plunder the country and it
was a much simpler process than the you
know the complicated over over invoicing
that you've described the process is
very simple you embezzle the money from
the state uh or you use some kind of
parallel to over invoicing and extract
the wealth from the national treasury
ascended abroad by property in London uh
and live like a king
and of course billions of dollars were
drained out of the country that way in
the Democracy collapsed in short order
all right so uh Raymond if we could get
into the details a little bit now
of secrecy capitalism and how it works
uh in uh in the global economy uh it's
not just over invoicing uh within
internal uh corporate trade you've got a
lot of uh examples here so can you kind
of elaborate on some of the other
dimensions of the problem uh and um then
we can get into some other aspects of
this
what I find fascinating and led to my
first book and led me to go further in
this book
is the realization that we in the
capitalist system have increa have
created an entire Financial secrecy
system to move and shelter and hide uh
uh money this system has a lot of
elements it comprises tax Havens these
are places where you can do business and
pay no taxes
um it comprises secrecy jurisdictions
these are places where you can set up an
entity
and do and nobody knows who owns the
entities
disguised corporations are in the tens
of millions around the world where
nobody knows who owns uh the businesses
and incidentally more of them were
created in the United States than in any
other countries
Anonymous trust accounts are part of
this structure you can use a trust
account to do business fake foundations
are part of this structure when you go
out and make your first billion you can
establish a charitable Foundation you
can donate your money to your charitable
foundation and you can designate
yourself as the beneficiary of the
charity of your foundation
paying no taxes
along the way
then
in
making this system work
we in the Richer countries in the United
States and Europe and uh
other parts of the world
have left holes in our national laws
that enable money to flow through this
financial secrecy system and ultimately
into our own economies the United States
is the biggest user of the financial
secrecy system and more of that money
comes to us than to any other country a
lot of people think oh this is
Switzerland or
this is the UK no this is the United
States more of that money flows to us
than to any other country I have been
fascinated for years by the degree to
which this undercuts uh the capitalist
system the degree to which it it it
hurts the operations of the capitalist
system and as we can get into further
Larry other things besides the
capitalist system right so it's a kind
of underground or beneath the surface
and well I would say very perverted form
of capitalism
but in order for these people around the
world uh to find the holes in the system
uh you argue I think quite convincingly
and to register their Anonymous show
corporations to buy their Anonymous real
estate to set up their fake charitable
trust and so on they need what you call
enablers and indeed an integrated and
very comprehensive system of enablers so
could you talk about them
a lot of people think that
um
corruption and money laundering and tax
evasion and all of that are the
systems that have been set up to
facilitate that have been done by other
people no every single part of the
financial secrecy system that I have
just described was created by us us in
the wealthier Western countries the
United States UK other parts of Europe
and so forth the entirety of this is and
I mean that drug dealers not not drug
dealers not criminal syndicates not
human traffickers none of those people
created any of this we created every
single part of the financial secrecy
system
you might ask why the
the first part of my first book is
entitled illegality
subtitle we like the money and it's just
that simple we like the money that this
system brings into our economies into
the UK into other wealthier economies
this financial secrecy system that is
that I described is not something that
other people have done to us it is what
we have done this is our creation every
part of it it's not something done to us
it's something done by us
so uh
let me ask a question
that kind of lurks at the 30 000 foot
level
it's almost philosophical or even
biological
um
these uh individuals who are not drug
traffickers and they haven't themselves
just stolen money from their National
treasury
their lawyers their accountants their
Auditors their real estate agents
they think of themselves I'm sure as
just you know making money in a
in a way that is permitted by the system
uh can can you I think you've met some
of these people you under the banks you
understand how they work
are are we talking about
no sorry this is just human nature are
we talking about the weaker elements of
human nature I mean how should we think
about
the motives surrounding this system of
participation and and enabling
I wondered for a long time how people
can participate in this system and and
not comprehend uh the bigger questions
of what it was doing
and I've I finally realized that some of
these enablers bankers and lawyers and
accountants and so forth actually have
it in their thinking that
money that is locked up in a corrupt
country or some place that is risky or
so forth that money should be brought
out and should be put in a safe place
where it can grow and generate profits
and so forth so the right thing to do is
to take the money out of there and bring
it to where it can be saved this is a
pretty self-justifying approach to this
but I have seen that operate
a lot of times
you there's another aspect of this Larry
and you have indicated that
um
a lot of these people are just abiding
by the law
not necessarily breaking the law
I would make a qualification to that and
that is that the capitalist system has
bought and paid for the laws that it
wants that make much of this stuff
perfectly legal so you know we've we the
capitalist system is paid
billions of dollars hundreds of billions
of dollars to produce the laws that that
vaguely facilitate this uh activity and
then as I said we our legislators very
much influenced by those people who are
pouring money into campaign
contributions
um pass the laws that enable these sorts
of things to go on the the fundamental
point that I'm that I'm making is that
that this is these machinations that
take place within the capitalist system
this is our doing it's not somebody else
quit and I have I have stood on
platforms and said let's stop blaming
those corrupt countries over there okay
let's look at ourselves because we are
the creators of this system we are the
people that have made the the that have
enabled this to go on and it's it's the
capitalist system buying what it wants
and paying the money to the legislators
through campaign contributions that are
necessary to have what we want so we've
got vast holds in our laws that
facilitate this okay I want to come to
those holes and how we fill them in a
minute but I have one more analytical
question before we do
um
uh you argue it's a major argument in
your book
that there is a deep and inescapable
relationship
between this system and frankly it's
it's acceleration in the in recent
decades and deepening inequality as well
as eroding democracy and not just
deepening inequality in the countries
from which wealth is being extracted and
sent back to Britain the United States
Switzerland
Etc I could say a lot more about that in
the case of Nigerian elsewhere but
deepening inequality in our own
countries so what's the link there
when I graduated from Harvard Business
School all those decades ago 1960.
the ratio between executive pay and
workers wages was 20 to 1.
that 1960 marked the close of the
15-year period following World War II
which in retrospect I think was the most
responsible period in American
capitalism that we've that we've ever
had
but beginning in the 1960s due to due to
some other things that I talk about uh
in my book beginning in the 1960s we
began to create the financial secrecy
system and and what is it done among
other things it's driven inequality that
20 to 1 ratio that existed in 1960
between executive pay and workers wages
today it's more than 350 to 1.
so we're talking about a phenomenon that
has driven inequality and I'm not about
to say that it is the sole explanation
for inequality but it is a major driving
force in inequality and the degree of
angst that that has caused
particularly within American society is
stunning we could we could talk
more about that
an analysis was done indicated if the 20
to 1 ratio in 1960 had maintained itself
as the U.S economy grew and it was still
21 to 20 to 1 today the middle class
would be better off by 50 trillion
dollars
every working class America knows every
employee in a major corporation knows
that his boss is making tens of millions
and he the worker is getting 10 cents an
hour more uh in his salary everybody
knows this disparity has exploded think
would have happened if it had not
exploded that's been a major driving
factor in inequality and it's had an
enormous impact on Democracy as we may
later get into Larry
yeah
um okay so we have uh the system of
financial secrecy in these various
Dimensions enabling and contributing to
not as the soul Factor but a powerful
let's say acceleron these shocking uh
intensifications of income and wealth
inequality around the world
and that alone I would say if you study
the literature on Democracy is not very
favorable for the future of democracy
and is producing a lot of the populist
backlash you see even if it backs some
of the uh creatures of this system
ironically enough but I want to in about
seven minutes get to questions from this
audience and our online audience so in
that time kind of you've got you know
half a book here of ideas about how to
reform and fix the system and it really
involves plugging a lot of holes and I'd
say meeting the devil in the details so
can you share some of your kind of
Reform priorities with us yes and let me
precede that them a little bit
after my first book was published we
we formed an organization called Global
Financial Integrity in order to very
optimistically try to influence Global
Financial Integrity a lot of other
organizations were also formed and we've
all been dealing with very particular
aspects
of the problem that I'm addressing we
we're dealing with human trafficking
we're dealing with organ
sales we're dealing with corruption
we're dealing with money laundering
issues all of us are dealing with
particularistic aspects of this and what
I finally realized
um several years ago is that we've got
to elevate this to a higher level we've
got to take our particularistic concerns
and say we are in fact dealing with a
problem that is much more fundamental
than just the uh
the particular details I was influenced
in coming to this uh realization by the
way the climate change issue moved
scientists and experts knew in the 1970s
and 80s and 90s that global warming was
a reality but this had not gotten into
the global Consciousness it was it was
in scholarly papers and among
among the experts and so forth but
finally Along Comes Al Gore and Al Gore
through his speeches and films and
presentations
and Oscar award and Nobel Peace Prize
and so forth he he drove this issue into
the global consciousness that's what has
to happen what I'm talking about has to
get into the global Consciousness I wish
I had the stature that Al Gore I could
make more progress in this but but we've
got to elevate these concerns to the
level that they get into the Overton
window into the window of comprehension
into the window of understanding that
this is a a huge threat to the
Democratic capitalist system does that
answer your question
uh it is the Prelude to answering my
question or or the overarching uh
Dimension to it and I will just add to
that well I'll say a couple of things
first of all
this man
he's not an academic okay he's not some
kind of Rosy tinted uh you know
political scientist or sociologist who's
spent his lifetime in the academy
you're looking at a businessman who has
made it clear to you he has run
companies he has bought companies and I
think it's fair to say you've enjoyed
making a profit right yes when you have
and there's a profit there's a growing
number of businessmen some of them even
more spectacularly successful than you
um we know who they are
um who are really worried deeply worried
about the trajectory we're on uh people
like Warren Buffett for example that
this level of inequality and this level
of shirking of responsibility you talk
of course about spiriting money out of
the country uh so people can evade among
other things paying the income tax they
know and the impoverishment and
de-capacitation of the IRS so that they
won't be audited this is not sustainable
that's a major theme of this book and I
also you refer you to Martin Wolf's new
book and particularly the title the
crisis of democratic capitalism that's
what we are in now and the the
capitalist part is is under assault it's
going to be under more focused assault
the Democracy part is under assault it's
and your argument Wolff's argument a lot
of the growing argument says the two
assaults are intimately interrelated so
in the last kind of three four minutes
before we go to questions give us some
of your favorite
policy
pluggings of the whole some you know
give us three or four reforms just as
illustration that you think could could
make a difference here legislatively or
by executive action let me lead into
that by continuing your line of
discussion for a moment and then we'll
get into how you solve the problem
capitalism and democracy
are the the two basic pillars of our
system and the systems of many other
countries capitalism is supposed to
offer a fair measure of prosperity to
its participants democracy is supposed
to offer an equal measure of political
Liberty to its uh its citizens these two
basic tenets
should be operating in sync but they are
not they are becoming decoupled
capitalism and democracy are becoming
decoupled and no longer operating in
sync to build prosperity and Liberty
this is a huge threat
um uh to you going forward you'll see
more of this in the future than I will
but this is a fundamental threat
how do you solve the problem the the big
answer is
transparency and accountability in the
capitalist
system the current reality is that
democracy is trying to operate with
transparency and capitalism is
determined to operate with secrecy and
these two things are not compatible they
won't work together you can't have one
system operating
aspirationally with transparency and the
other system operating determinately in
secrecy they are in conflict and that
conflict is impacting so much of of
our experiences
at at this at this present time how do
you solve the problem transparency and
accountability let's take the issue of
of disguised corporations shell
companies that we've talked about more
of them as I said create in the United
States than in any other country
um
after 9 11 give you an example of how
you solve the problem of shell companies
after 9 11 the United States passed the
Patriot Act Patriot Act is is
controversial in a lot of aspects but it
has an anti-money laundering component
in it that is quite strong among other
things the Patriot Act addressed the
issue of shell Banks I don't talk about
shell Banks anymore because they've been
taken off the table how did we take
shell Banks off the table which were
banks that nobody knew who owned them
and they operated all over uh the world
how did we take shell Banks off the
table
Patriot Act says no U.S corporation can
receive money from a shell Bank
it goes on to say no other Bank in the
world can send money to the United
States that it has received from a shell
Bank it goes on to make it clear that
this applies to wire transfers that
might touch a New York City
correspondent banking account before
flitting off to go somewhere else with
this blanket prohibition against shell
Banks shell Banks disappeared from the
Global Financial secrecy system just
like that gone no Bank in the world was
prepared to risk losing its access to
the U.S financial system by dealing with
some other shell Bank all it took was a
clear-cut Prohibition against doing it
you can do the same thing with shell
companies if we had the courage to do so
just make it illegal you can't receive
money
from a shell company now
um
Larry you asked some questions earlier
about
isn't this
complicated regulation there is no
regulation in U.S law for adjusting
shell Banks there is no office in the
treasury Department that says
um you know we're going to monitor shell
banks around the world and the reason is
because there are no showbacks we took
it off the table just like that you can
take this guy's corporations off the
table just like that you can address the
issue of falsified trade that business
of of misinvoicing trade transactions
you can curtail that I have recommended
to probably a dozen developing countries
that I've done
that Global Financial Integrity has
worked with I've recommended that they
should adopt a law that says no company
domestic or foreign owned
um
can utilize trade for the purpose of
evading or avoiding vat taxes customs
duties income taxes excise taxes or any
other source of global Revenue
put that into your law but then go a
step further and that is require that in
submitting your annual tax returns or
annual accounts you the managing
director of that entity have to sign a
statement that you have cars that you
have
followed that regulation put your
signature on it
this this would curtail a great deal of
the centerpiece of the financial secrecy
system trade misinvoicing falsified
trade transfer pricing
it's all the same stuff
developing countries should put in law
that you can't do this and then require
managing directors to sign that they
have complied by that it won't end it
all together no law will end anything
altogether but it will certainly curtail
it and that's that's the big thing
that I want to do
um Banks Banks
receive money from abroad
um they don't necessarily have to know
where it comes from
um
Banks want to bend over backwards to
facilitate the free exchange of money
well it has gotten to the point that
Banks if they see dirty money they are
expected to file a currency transaction
report or a suspicious
transaction report
um and you would think that this is just
happens only occasionally they see this
kind of money and they have to file
these kinds of reports can you imagine
how many suspicious activities reports
and currency transaction reports are
filed
on average 80
000 a day
what I'm saying is that U.S banks will
take every dollar of money that comes
across the transom provided they can
come up with some flimsy excuse for
doing so and then simply file a report
um uh with the U.S financial
intelligence agency this is unworkable
Banks should have to be
the beginning point is Banks should know
um where the money is coming from who
are The Beneficial owners of those
entities that are sending money here if
I was a banker I wouldn't do business
with whom I didn't know who I was doing
business with I would see to it that I
knew with whom I was doing business this
is this is not rocket science this is
entirely a matter of political will a
lot of Bankers will say oh no no this
stuff is terribly complicated you don't
understand how complicated it is
nonsense it's terribly simple if you
have the will to do it this is entirely
a matter of political will it is not a
matter of complications it it the
solution to these problems are greater
transparency and accountability
in financial matters give you just one
more example addressing the question of
of inequality I think it's time to put
workers on corporate Boards of uh of
directors this this disparity between
rich and poor is a is a threatening uh
problem we've gotten to the point
globally and I and very close close to
this point I won't say
quite that we globally we've gotten to
the point that the richest one percent
has wealth comparable to the remaining
99 percent wealth of the richest one
percent comparable to the remaining 99
percent
inequality has exploded in the United
States one of the easy ways to address
that problem is put workers on Boards of
directors Elizabeth Warren has said
she'd like to see 40 percent of boards
comprised of workers I don't know
whether the right percentage is but get
the voice there on the board of
directors that you getting a 10 million
dollar raise and me getting a 10 cent an
hour raise that isn't going to continue
to work we've have to we have to change
this lots of things that can be done in
the realm of current of of transparency
and accountability to address these I
was going to say it's a very rich menu
but I don't think that's the right
adjective uh so let's go to q a right
now and you got a question from online
Tom or
sure I'd love to ask a question for
online the online audience thanks you
for being here as well as the in-person
audience we really appreciate it we
agree with a lot of what you're saying
we agree that there's plugs or holes
that need to be plugged that often
transparency is the sort of the the best
medicine but there is a little bit of
pushback that enforcement is in fact
required and an example of this might be
regulation with laborers and uyghur or
outbound versus inbound cypheus regimes
so do you think that enforcement is in
fact required after regulation and to
what extent oh yeah I'm I'm all in favor
of uh of enforcement I'm in favor of the
regulations and the adequate enforcement
I think part of the reason that uh
Silicon Valley Bank failed was a lack of
uh enforcement of regulations that were
in place
but let me make a a larger point
transparency can do more than regulation
I just
indicated the example of signing your
name on the accounts that you file give
me transparency and it takes the place
of a lot of of Regulation I would I
would I'm arguing for greater
transparency
um and and that's it's not synonymous
with uh greater regulation on the
contrary transparency can make
um
transparency can lessen the need for
regulation the example I give you I gave
you of getting shell banks on the table
there is no regulation of uh trying to
get of following the activities of shell
Banks because they're gone
there's there's there's no enforcement
there's no uh regulation we uh we outlaw
them they're gone you can do the same
thing with a lot of the aspects of of of
of what I'm talking about sure we're
always going to have Tran regulation and
enforcement issues
um but those demands are lessened in a
system that operates with transparency
and accountability
I'd like did you want to ask yeah I did
have I own the enforcement and showing
that
um so
you know there's a lot of Faking that's
possible these days so
I even with transparency what is
a signature mean somebody has
to check it so you know the beneficial
owner's requirement now is only to the
extent that they've passed a little bit
of it recently but not not implemented
yet in the U.S maybe uh still doesn't
have the apparatus to really make it
work so I do think that you know
I I'm not sure how the the that works
that the showbanks disappear because
there must have been some sanction
attached to the ones that break that
rule because oftentimes there's no
enforcement for people to spray it
you're asking how shell Banks
disappeared
the punishment attached is that if we
find you're doing it you lose your
access to the U.S financial system
but my point is there's no follow-up
regulation because nobody is prepared to
take that risk
um
yeah I'll let me go a step further with
this business of shell companies and how
to
address that problem I'm in favor of
every country having a
um digitally and publicly available
company registry
where every company's ownership
is is understood is known and that
information is available digitally and
publicly give me that
um
listen this this business of the United
States having created Millions tens of
millions of disguised entities is
perfectly ridiculous here we are in the
state of California why is the state of
California doing something in secret
that you don't know about and you can't
find out about it I live in Maryland
after Delaware
um
created the opportunity for disguised
entities are you aware that every other
state in the United States followed suit
every other state in the United States
followed suit to enable companies to be
established so that you can't find out
who owns that company that's ridiculous
you ought to be able for the state to do
something in your name and you can't
find out about it uh there's there's no
justification for that now at the
federal level you got secret agents that
have to do their stuff in secret but
that's not true at the state level
so we're not there who's there
European Court uh struck down the uh the
efforts in Europe to establish publicly
available beneficiary Registries on the
notion that it was it was an attack on
privacy
and my answer to that and I make it very
clear at the beginning of my book my
answer to that is there's a difference
between privacy and secrecy
you know I'd like my bike my bank
account to remain private
but that doesn't mean secret if somebody
with a name similar to mine is accused
of a terrorist act and appropriate
authorities need to look at uh bank
account information go right ahead my my
privacy is not above your security your
personal security so I'm I'm really
upset with the uh the court in Europe
and also with the slow movement of
establishing the regulations
um uh in in the United States
they will the U.S laws the corporate
transact corporate transparency act will
not make that information available
publicly it should be in the commercial
realm there's no reason for for you not
to be able to know with whom you're
dealing not to be able to know with
what's being authorized
on your behalf
write to a statement uh
said
transparency is
so we are we're doing with research and
financial technology so if you
theoretically you could make transparent
all the payment transactions the world
above worldwide so all the
International payments every Everything
could be drawn and not transparent so if
you currently maybe also follow the
discussion about Central bank's digital
currencies which are um
digital currencies issued by by central
banks which would allow all the central
banks on the monitoring and tracking on
a global basis do you think this would
be kind of a cure for the financial
system also maybe pretty
such
fraud and every everything or
do you think that this won't happen
that's an interesting question and and
the juries is somewhat out as to where
this issue goes
um let's draw a distinction between
digital currencies and cryptocurrencies
cryptocurrencies are in fact a
subcategory of the larger definition of
of digital currencies
many central banks around the world are
thinking about setting up digital
currencies
um and I don't see anything wrong with
this what it means is you can you can
download to your cell phone money and
use that to pay for things
um but that's that's got a large measure
of transparency and and traceability
to it
cryptocurrencies are an entirely
different uh uh question
um the last time I looked at the number
there were something like 10
000 cryptocurrencies that had been set
up around the world and they vary from
the ones that are completely uh
invisible to the ones that have some
aspects of Securities and are coming
under the regulation of the Securities
and Exchange Commission
um
digital I'm sorry cryptocurrencies that
operate completely invisibly
um I hope you're not losing your money
all these uh
yeah I hope you I hope you know let's
let's be perfectly clear
cryptocurrencies that are the most
hidden
have nothing but narrative value that is
to say they can be talked up or they can
be talked down but there is no
underlying
asset that gives that gives that value
so you got to be brave to put a lot of
your money into a cryptocurrency and
then in particular to let that get put
into a cryptocurrency exchange that is
operating completely out of sight
um
you don't you don't have to imagine much
that I'm not a favor I'm not a fan of
cryptocurrencies
digital currency is perfectly uh
perfectly all right another online
question following cryptocurrencies it
seems again we got a spicy online
audience that likes to push back a
little bit that the Overton window seems
to already be open and people are
talking about anonymity and they want
some from themselves cryptocurrency
Robin Hood Professor Becky Lester
sitting behind me as a forthcoming paper
about uh different kinds of corporate
structures being used given that's the
current Zeitgeist can you talk about
some non-market players unions religion
the press that are also sort of feeding
this that are also in the crypto space
that are that are also sort of
exacerbating this problem of invisible
money invisible capitalism well go back
to the financial secrecy system I'm
sorry go back to the financial crisis of
2007 and eight there were an awful lot
of Pension funds and religious
organizations both in the United States
and abroad the just lapped up these
mortgage-backed Securities in the uh in
the hundreds of millions of dollars and
they lost
um so you know the to me the short
answer is know what you're putting your
money into have some understanding uh of
it I read the story about one woman who
had lost her half million dollars life
savings uh
um in the collapse of
um FDX
um Samuel backman Freed's
entity
why would you take your life savings and
put them in a in an asset that has no
underlying value and then have that put
in exchange that is operating completely
uh in the dark
to me it makes no makes no sense digital
currencies make sense crypto doesn't in
in my thinking and I suppose just to
clarify the question even outside of
cryptocurrency is there a role that the
press or non-market players might be
having in exacerbating the problem of
invisible money
um without question
um a lot of a lot of hype surrounding
cryptocurrencies
a lot of uh
concerned that this is I had a podcast
in connection with my book in which the
guy said this is reality it's here
there's nothing you can do about it well
that may be true
um there have been
um a couple of studies of cryptocurrency
transactions that indicate that the
um
the level of money laundering that is
going on is perhaps 50 percent of
cryptocurrency uh transactions they're
being used for money laundering uh
purposes
um that's that's not healthy for the
capitalist system
I think that sounds like a good warning
on which to conclude
um let me just make two substantive
points and then a procedural point the
substantive points are
um that um if the need is in part for
transparency the media is obviously a
very important part of the solution uh
and there is some reference to that in
here and the role of the what is it
International Consortium of uh of
investigative journalists which revealed
the Panama papers and a lot of the money
laundering and so on and so forth so I
see Independent Media as I know you do
Raymond as a big part of the solution
here in the Quest for transparency and
then just ratcheting it up one more
level I will quote with the slight
change in pronouns uh our most important
constitutional framer James Madison if
people were angels we would have no need
of government People Are Not Angels it's
you know unless you want to do uh you
know a genetic fix of the human species
and God knows where that would lead
this is part of the problem we're
inclined to war we're inclined to Greed
there's a lot of human defects and what
keeps Humanity civil Democratic you know
inclined toward progress are uh if I may
say so democracy the rule of law
transparency accountability and
um making this kind of Deceit and greed
not pay too risky to engage in so I
think that is one way if I may say so of
framing the vital message of this book
and it turns out we have copies of the
book here uh I guess that people can
people can
aren't we
in a free market system where people
have to pay for uh well I do believe
Raymond will sign your book if you want
to get one and so big thanks to Raymond
Baker big thanks to uh anat Ahmadi and
Kasi and thank you all for coming
[Applause]
[Music]